considering the current state of affairs
there are many people who have asked or
have suggested or wondered how it is
exactly
that you can be a
conservative rebel or a rebel in a time
when a system is becoming tyrannical and
so i thought that we could look at how
exactly you could do that and the best
way to look at that question
is of course to look at the story of
king david in the story of king david we
will find some very surprising imagery
some very surprising uh use of symbolism
that will
help us understand when it is that we
have to be something like
the snake that avoids being caught or
something like the
the person who is dancing around the
tyrannical system
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
so in the story of king david king saul
represents very much the tyrannical king
and you can see that he represents the
tyrannical king because
the reason why god is displeased
displeased with him is because
king saul tries to take the sacrifice
upon himself at least he tries to act
as the spiritual authority to take away
the power from the spiritual authority
and sacrifice before the prophet arrives
to who is the one who's supposed to do
the sacrifice the other place where king
saul disappoints
uh is when he does not obey
the rule that god gives now that rule is
a very uh very dark and extreme rule
that he receives from god and
one day we'll look at what that is
talking about but for now it's mostly
important to understand that in the
story the reason why he is seen as a
tyrannical king is that he wants to
concentrate power himself take it away
from the prophet and ultimately you
could say even um
let's say
think that he can decide instead of god
and so because because saul is a
tyrannical king then the prophet samuel
will anoint david god will tell samuel
to anoint david
to be the replacement of king saul now
at the outset
king david is hidden
he it is not public that he is the
future king
at the moment he is
he is hidden he is seeking he is the
secret king
um and as the secret king it will become
necessary for him to actually resist the
tyranny of king saul now what's really
interesting is to notice to what extent
king david takes on the role uh
takes on images of all that is dark all
that is
shifty
all that is strange all that is insane
he takes on all that symbolism in the
moment when he is resisting king saul
and so it really is a perspective from
the point of view of someone who wants
to resist the system and in order to do
so must take the role
of that on which the system is trying to
rule or that which is the the kind of
bubbling chaos which is at the bottom of
the world now
this starts with the very image of the
fact that the way that david was
inserted into king saul's court was that
he was asked to come sing for king saul
now if you read my brother's book you
will see that the fact that you have the
king standing there and then you have
king david who is playing music
trying to calm down the king's arter
trying to soothe him and you'll see that
at first he does sue them at the outset
king david plays music for the king and
and soothes the the character so you can
actually see interestingly enough king
dev david playing the role of the the
jester the entertainer the this this
kind of
the moment when uh work stops
entertainment all of that in order to
act as a
counterpoint to the excess of the
tyrannical king now
but then once king one king saul is
going to start to be jealous of king of
david because you have that moment when
king david kills goliath
and so
king saul becomes jealous of david and
so now
starts to look out for him and this is
where you're going to see some very
interesting symbolism
now once again
david is standing there and he's playing
music for king saul that's what he
represents all that is all that is
related to time for exam in matthew's
book all that is related to the informal
to the un to the un let's say unnamed or
something which is not fixed something
which is moving something which is
rhythmic
and
what does king saul try to do
he tries to
jab david with his
lance
and tries by that to pin him to the wall
that's what it says on scripture in
scripture and so you can understand that
king king saul's desire to jab
david right to pierce him with a lance
is akin to something like
you know pinning an insect into a
you know putting an insect down into a
display case he's trying to fix him he's
trying to stop him from playing music
he's trying to stop him from being that
shifty character he wants to name him
and now we in this image we see
that the negative aspect of naming that
is that there is an aspect of naming
which if we if if we're not careful
about naming can utterly fix something
can prevent it from
having its malleability it's
idiosyncracy right it's too much light
too much identity can be a very
dangerous thing because it can it can
freeze something can freeze it into
death and you can see that with people
who are you know too obsessed with with
naming too obsessed with control is that
if you exercise too much control over a
system then you can actually [ __ ] it
into
into immobility right you can kill it by
piercing it and so
uh it's very fascinating to see that
king saul wants to jab david that this
is related to fixing him to you could
say something like uh
stopping him from moving totally
identifying him totally capturing david
you know like as if he was a wild animal
as if he was a uh
as if he was something that he's hunting
right to hunt him down to find him to
fix him uh and this is now an image of
the uh the tyrannical state or the
tyrannical king that wants to fully
master
and at that in in that mastery tried to
kill it it has something to do with i've
talked about the notion of the the
system of the beast or the the excess of
naming which comes in all that imagery
of 666 symbolism and the idea of marking
something right marking it in a manner
that is complete so that there is no
remainder trying to of trying to make it
so that there is absolutely no remainder
that everything is captured by the
system now of course in our case this
can be completely related to
technocratic societies to societies of
surveillance societies of tracking
and we can see how right now this is
being very much accelerated by the the
state trying to jab us and trying to jab
us in a way that fixes us and makes us
participate in a system of naming in
which there should not be any remainder
and this is why there's so much
obsession with
making sure everybody is part of the
system you know and so this is what is
happening around us so it's interesting
to see the manner in which david resists
this now
this is the one some of the craziest
symbolism that you'll ever see because
once david who is the future king the
king in hiding becomes a
let's say becomes a target for the uh
tyrannical system then david will take
on all the symbolism
of the opposite all the symbolism of the
strange of the enemy and of madness and
this of course interestingly enough
starts with
a moment where king david isn't sure
whether or not saul is really angry with
him and whether or not saul still wants
to kill him so after david runs away you
know when paul when saul tries to depend
him to the wall he comes back and then
he speaks to his friend jonathan
and uh
he asked jonathan like you know what
what's the situation and jonathan is
telling him
i'm gonna go back to see my my father
and you stay here
and so if my father
asks for you that is if he asks for you
in an angry way that is if he wants to
know where you are if he wants to make
sure he knows where you are that you've
been properly tracked then it means that
you're in danger if he's angry that
you're not there that he wants you to be
in his court then you'll know that
you're in danger but if he does if it
doesn't bother him that you're not fully
in his court that you're not there at
this moment that will know that you're
not in danger so
jonathan goes back and then realizes
that king saul gets very angry because
david is not there but what's
interesting is the sign that david that
jonathan gives to david
so he says when i come back i'm going to
you're going to hide next to a target
and then i'm going to shoot an arrow
right i'm going to miss the target
and the manner in which i miss the
target
is going to be a symbol
it's going to be an image of what you
need to do whether you should come back
or whether you should go away now this
is extremely interesting if you
understand the notion of transgression
if you understand the notion of sin that
here in this situation
missing the target not hitting the mark
is the manner in which the shifty
character that david now represents you
know the kind of
the the
the wild character that he's becoming is
to know what to do
and so you can understand what's going
on that things are really
david is really
representing now
in a very strange way something like
the
the dragon that is avoiding to be
pierced by say michael but here in this
case it's it's of course
david which is the good we'll see why he
is the good in this case and why he's
not he's not the the same type of dragon
that you see in this in the icon of san
michonne the dragon but the imagery is
the same right say michael is trying to
pierce the dragon he's trying to fix the
dragon and it's funny because a lot of
people have pointed out to me that the
image of say michael you know smashing
his his lance in the dragon's mouth
looks like you know the covet test looks
like you're receiving a cover test and
there's something about that there's
something intuitive about the idea of
being penetrated by the state in a
manner in which they want to do that in
order to
to make sure that you're part of their
system and to kind of make you
understand
your position vis-a-vis the state you
know um
and so you can see that that
if you don't if you if you think that
that's stretching it there are some
governments for example the chinese
government which allegedly were using
other types of penetrations in order to
know whether or not you had covet which
is obviously not necessary at all but it
can help you understand what it is
that's going on that is
that is there is something
there's something which is even
sometimes beyond the the the people that
are implementing it that they don't
necessarily i'm not saying this is
planned to be this way but it's still
manifesting a pattern of penetrating and
related to identity and fixing
it's just there so what does king david
do now king david obviously has to now
run away and in his running away it is
so
fascinating what happens
first of all
he has to hide inside the temple
and in hiding inside the temple
he
the priest end up giving him the the
food the bread that is in the
the holy place the bread that is for the
priest and so
you'd say what is going on like what
what is happening and so
the priests are giving him the bread he
is not taking it for himself that's very
important and that you can maybe say
that that's the difference between him
and king saul which is that in a manner
david is now engaging in a form of
transgression
right but this transgression
there's something innocent about the
transgression and this is where we're
going to start to see the difference
there's something innocent in his
transgression but it's not only that
what does david receive when he goes to
see go into the temple he received
goliath his sword
now receiving goliath is stored will be
compounded by the fact that david will
then go and associate himself with the
philistines will actually go to the city
from which goliath comes from and will
place himself under the guard
guardianship of the
the kings and the people responsible for
the philistines
and he
pretends to fight for the enemy
uh it's this is very interesting but
there are other scenes where he also
pretends to be crazy he feigns madness
uh and then he assembles a band of he
assembles with in in the wilderness he
assembles in a cave with a band of
debtors and a band of you know shady
people and so
these gestures are all gestures about
you know moving into the margin becoming
going down into the cave going into
death
aligning yourself with the stranger
aligning yourself with your enemy
all of these things in a way that i've
warned you about that happens on the
periphery now this is what david is
doing
and so what is the difference between
david and just a traitor what's the
difference between david and a regular
thief and a regular debtor
and the answer is
something like his intention
what is his intention
and how does that intention play itself
out during the story now
this might seem like like it's a trick
or might seem like it's something off
but
you can see if you look at the story
carefully you'll notice for example
when david is working with the
philistines
he makes the philistines the the enemies
i forget if it now if it's the
philistines but one of the enemy tribes
of the israelites he pretends that he's
fighting for them that he's actually
fighting the israelites but in secret
he is defending them and he's
and he is doing other things
he's attacking other tribes while they
think that he's with the enemy when he
when he
he acts crazy he's actually pretending
to be crazy in order to get away from
his enemy and then when he comes at a
moment dark deep down in the cave
where he's hiding and then king saul
comes down in the cave
and king saul
this is this is one of the most powerful
images of understanding how
what's going on in this story so king
saul goes down into the cave where david
is hiding
and king saul doesn't know david's there
and king saul goes there to
do his business you know it's it says to
cover his feet
you know and while he is down there
doing his business david uh sneaks up
behind him while he's going about
and he cuts off the fringe
of his vestment
then when he leaves the camp when he
when saul leaves the cave
king david
brandishes
the fringe of the vestment
of saul
as a guarantee
that he is not there to kill the king
that he has the fringe
but that he he has no intention of
killing the the king so this is really
the difference between david and a
revolutionary it's the difference
between
a
the difference between a protest an
antifa protest and the trucker convoy
look at the differences between the two
and so one of them let's say the antifa
protest wants to
wants to usurp the government wants to
destroy the the the
the power of the state wants to um hate
you know anything about the nation is
hiding their faces you know is
destructive uh attacks federal buildings
does all that you saw that in 2020. we
saw that during the floyd protest antifa
attacked federal buildings in the u.s
for months on end
if you look at the trucker convoy
protests what you have are people waving
the flag of their country
you know hundreds of canadian flags and
hundreds of quebec flags
and and people basically being extremely
respectful to police you know going up
there fist bumping the police and i've
seen it myself i was there in ottawa you
know the the truckers are extremely
respectful of authority extremely
respectful police but are saying
we know this is
this is
edgy like we know that what we're doing
is maybe illegitimate in its practice
but that the intent is we want to
restore
the rule of law we want to restore the
identity of our nation now you can argue
with them whether or not this is
with is which is what what
what ultimately it'll do or not and you
can argue with them whether or not you
think they're misguided or that they're
in air but you can still see the
difference between something like a
conservative rebel who is acting in a
rebellious manner he's acting in a
technically sinful manner that is is
willing to miss the mark or to avoid the
mark
in order to not propagate a tyranny but
rather point their own
country their own
higher identity towards eight towards a
higher purpose
and so you see that of course also in
the same situation where king david
walks into the camp while saul is
sleeping and then
he finds the a lance i think he actually
finds saul's lands so you have a sense
in which he could take that lance and
could now do the same to saul that saul
tried to do to him to pin him to the
ground right to
to to stop him in his tracks to fix him
but instead he plants the the lance
above saul's head
and therefore spares him
and also
shows you exactly what's going on
that is that's how that's the difference
where
are you looking
you if you resist the system you have to
be doing it in a way that's looking
above the system that's looking towards
a higher point a higher point of
attention towards something you can
resist the system when a system becomes
corrupt as long as you have your
attention towards what is right and what
is virtuous and of course in a certain
manner you could say
history will judge you and and maybe
there's a man in which it's a tricky
position to be because to a certain
extent you can understand the criticism
of those that do that but we see that
example
in the story of the church
constantly right my own patron saint
saint maximus is a wonderful example of
that
where saint maximus
thought that the emperor was wrong in
his theological pronouncements
and he said no and the emperor said
look look around us
everybody agrees with me the patriarch
of constantinople agrees with me you
know everybody agrees with me
why won't you agree with me
and say maximus
said no i cannot agree with you i will
not go along with your system
because he was looking above he was
looking higher and you could see
that there was error in the way that
that the king
was at the emperor was acting and that
the patriarch was acting
and so
like i said it's a tricky position to be
because to a certain extent you also
kind of have to accept the consequences
of doing that you have to accept the
consequences that if you're going
to
to want to avoid a tyrannical system if
you're going to want to point to a
higher meaning
that means that you will become the
victim of the system you know and
that's the position we're in right now
you know i uh
i mentioned this before but right now in
our province in quebec they are
demanding people use
vaccine passports in order to go to
church and to me
that is
a problem of hierarchy
and so at that point when this when
these things start to happen
then there is no choice
but to position yourself
as someone who is
resisting a illegitimate
tyranny a tyranny which is excessive in
its grasp which is trying to take the
powers of god for themselves
an authority which is trying to name
without exception which refuses to leave
a fringe
and sometimes
it becomes the role of actually the
conservative person who
who actually believes in hierarchy
to
raise up that fringe and show it back to
the authority and remind them
remind them of the fringe and the need
to leave an exception that you cannot
encompass everything that you are not
god
uh and do it and trying to encompass
everything
is going to lead to massive chaos and a
massive breakdown
and so i hope this was helpful i hope
it's helping you understand
some of the things that i've been saying
in the past few weeks some of the things
that i've been doing on social media but
it's just starting because uh this is
happening now and uh
and uh so uh so thanks for your support
everybody thanks for your attention and
uh you might have noticed there are a
few maybe a few less videos as usual
these days but hopefully um
as my attention starts to focus back
again then we will have more of that
coming very soon
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please uh
go ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support